je te ben ali de salem décès at on
jamais
des villageois avait raison de craindre
la magie trouve toujours le moyen de
venir c'est mon cadeau pour tes 16 ans
j'ai un cadeau pour mes deux clientes
préférées
tu sais ce qu'on dit ou sorcière et
rites ses pouvoirs le jour de ses 16 ans
[Musique]
nos enfants à l'abri oui c'est nous tu
ne rêves pas qu'il porte où est ce que
tu as trouvé cette bougie il faut mettre
le gris moral après les sorcières vont
arriver là les me regardes quoi il te
plait
si on veut rester en vie après le lever
du soleil qui font leur voler leur
jeunesse attendez s'il vous plaît est ce
qu on pourrait en parler
dans les airs
[Musique]
français bras le carreau car au cas où
sa 40e rapporte
veut pas s'inquiéter mais avec une
horrible sorcière prête à tout pour se
venger
c'est très mal parti pour ses lèvres
il faut qu'on profite du sel pourquoi
qu'on est meilleur goût que des
moucherons
[Musique]
on est atteint
je vais par là et toi par marie
c'est pas six pieds sous terre ça
[Musique]
du calme rassure gentil zambie